oh this is why do you give me questions
that white people are going to cancel
[Music]
what's up guys I'm Kim Congdon and I'm
doing answer the internet would you
rather your girlfriend or boyfriend be
able to read your thoughts during sex or
all the time except during sex 100 I
would want them to read my thoughts
during sex because then they could be
better
give me some tips yeah that's exactly
what they need to read my thoughts not
during sex is gonna hurt them more than
it was yeah for sure easy question easy
would you rather have a three inch dick
or only last 30 seconds during sex let
me tell you as as the man I'd rather
have the three
I think because then I'd learn to eat
good [__] yeah as if I'm the woman
receiving I'd rather have only the 30
seconds because I feel like I could
mentally train myself to come in 30
seconds
[Applause]
see I think the problem with three is
like you can be good at eating [__] and
good at everything else but like the
visual and like people knowing that you
have a three inch dick is tough yeah
well to be honest like like if you're
with a guy that like he's just good at
eating [__] it's just like if all your
meals were dessert
eventually we want something Savory
[Applause]
starts out quickly you're sick of ice
cream it's like a chicken sandwich if I
could
make it six inches
oh this is why do you give me questions
that white people are gonna cancel
five kittens in a row or one dog I feel
like you get drunk on blood after like
like three years
[Applause]
the bloody cats in here
like if you killed ten you can kill a
God
yeah once you're past five you feel
nothing
no I'm going to say the cat because I'm
allergic to cats and that's just less
trouble for me
the cats would probably win 25 cats
would beat you 25 cats no more yeah yeah
I'm putting the cat in an arm bar baby
what's the youngest age child that you
could beat up
oh beat me up if they're training I got
beat by um
I got beat by like an eight-year-old a
few times she was like eight or nine and
she's a and she's a girl and she was a
beast and the thing about the kids is
they're so squirrely they like come on
your back have you ever seen like a like
a homeless person with a pet squirrel
like that's how kids will bite you so
that is a great Visual and when you're
in your 30s you can't move your neck
that fast so I would say about 10. what
would you treat a three-year-old baby
for I would trade a three-year-old baby
in exchange for
a man with a dick bigger than three
inches
[Laughter]
how long would you have to starve to
become a cannibal
I know who wrote this one not you
getting hard when I said it
um
oh man it would have to be I mean what
how long can you go without eating
probably like 10 days 10 days I think
you can go like five days without water
is a lot quicker I know that I don't
know I think eating is like 10 days so a
brown I think around eight your thighs
would start looking nice
yo let her do that the other day that uh
like the way to tell nurses in the
hospital to kill you is to keep refusing
water
if you say that bill like this means we
need to get him help he's planning
suicide this whole hour
it's been a decade oh my gosh we want
you here
I always think of uh
Tom seguro says he's like I'm not
suicidal but how many days are there
left yeah can you imagine the day you
wake up no you're just like today's the
day tomorrow's not gonna happen I'm
gonna go to the clinic and that's it
can't imagine like attention too much
yeah it would give me attention but I
wouldn't be there that's a haunting
that's worse than living
if you had to choose one cartoon animal
to have sex with who would it be I've
had this answer since I was eight years
old I would [__] the [__] out of Scar
from Lion King oh that's very nice oh
you have deep problems everyone you are
a teenage Simba you go scar you got
problems bro that's dark it's weird that
they say Teenage symbols
they got problems too at least I'm
[__] an adult lion
do I have problems he has green eyes he
has a scar on his face he hates his
brother he's gonna throw his brother
into a [__] Stampede and tried to
kill his nephew and then if you believe
the internet ate his brother yeah that's
right what there's a scene like after
that you see him like like licking his
lips and people think he was and he's
playing with the skull that's right and
it looks like yeah so like he eats but
there are no other there are no animals
in the wild that eat lions other than
lions
I think he's hotter now
you can turn any movie into a porno with
the same cast from the movie which movie
are you picking any movie into a porno
I hate to say this Lion King
we could put any franchise restaurant in
your house what would it be you know
what
oh you [__] trash bags I mean you get
coffees you get sodas you get the fat
cashier you get snacks you get
everything to [__] gas station
it's right there yeah yeah don't you
guys like Publix down there yeah yeah
but
well it's a little dirty I like that
well it was like a dive bar yeah
a hotel rooftop
if you could [__] anyone you wanted but
they'd die immediately after who would
you pick oh I [__] love this question
most of the men I like yeah
they could never have anyone else again
uh assigned to Puerto Rican
[Applause]
who do you think is the oldest someone's
been when they've had sex
the oldest I could muster even if it was
for myself I mean I plan on living till
I'm 122 and then dying naturally while
coming
um so in doing heroin
because I can't get addicted and I can't
like walk out to the streets suck dick
for it
I just want to like be in my bed doing
heroin I've never done it before but it
sounds fun when you're old in bed
too I've never done it when I'm crying
kicking my face
um
I would say probably I'm there's
definitely people in their hundreds
getting it on I mean yeah it probably
smells like old baby powder what do you
think's household [__] your old dick
oh I already I already I already did
this research old [__] is way worse an
old dick looks kind of like a young dick
if you take away the balls but an old
[__] looks like someone gave up on
folding a fitted sheet oh my God
that's a great visual that's how I know
God's a man oh my 11 would never do this
to our [__] she knows
whose old [__] did you see
oh my God Google's got a [__] we had to
watch one category of porn for the rest
of your life what would it be lesbian
lesbian lesbian lesbian lesbian
yeah that's porn that's terrible it's
terrible it's terrible porn yeah he
hates seeing women come
okay
if you could have one person narrate or
do a play-by-play of you having sex who
would it be everyone's gonna say Morgan
Freeman not me I want a lot of people do
say that I want pre-dead Gilbert Godfrey
[Applause]
she's got a nice [__] on her
thank you
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out